OF THE RACISTHER ILED MOME
STORE.S ISABEL ROSALES HAS MOREN
THE  ATTACK TH
BAA HERO FORNGOFTH WHO LATERNE
FIRE AT A DOAR
IDA.E TERED
USPPENSTANCENOT ARFLORICALLY BLE
ON A WHIM THLO FIRST HISCABLACK
>> Reporter:
SHERIFF T.K. WATERS, PIC
HAVEN'T FOUNY EVIDENTO ATT
UNIVERSITY.
D ADVISED THATER LOT
DROVE
OFF AFTERT
>> HD NOW Y FLOWERS AND Y GRIEC
HEATT ABOUT EVERYONE
HE MADE THATERY CLEAR.
CT WITA RMATION ABOUT THE GUNMA
HANDGUN AND AN AR-15 RIFLE
WITH SWASTASIT
THEN HE OPENEDIRE.
T HIY.WHNG IT.ter: THEOT HAD NO
AS A TEENAGER BEINORARILINN FLO'
BAKER AC72 HOURS.
>> IONW LEGALLY THE WAE WRIT TH
E WAS  THAD HA BEEN
ES FRUSTRATION FORMES.
Rr: A.JLA
N.
>> WE'REG TOIGE OUT UGHTER THAT
GONE.OUGH WD .
OT
>> RepteK IN
FLORIDA THE LATESTN ER HOOTINGS
D , SOH NCDE
I'M ANGRY.
, AS PN,L  W
THAT'S WHA WAS. WAS PLANNING AN
EXUTED THREE
>> Ror WE HAVE
INFORMATION FROM ARE S HAPPENIN
W AT SHERIFF'SFICE.
ES REVEALING THAT THE R PRIO WOE
THIS I GENERAL WHE
THIS SHOOTING HAPPENED.ALSOELEAE
WE'RNO OF THE
CHNOE
INDICATE, THE SHOOTER GOING INTO
A FAMILY DIFFERE
STORE.IS OF TERS UNIVERSITY, TH.
WE GOING
BEHIND A VEHICLE AND PUTTING
A TACTICAL VEST.
WE KNOW MITES  HE OWED UP AT TDR
GENERAL.
THE FINAL PIE T IEUS S OF POLIC
THIS DOLLAR
THAT IS WHENIES Y S OWLIFE.
JA
ISABEL ROLE
TSO MUCH.
CASTOV DAYHAS TURDHOOTINGS IJACO
ELEBRAYEARS OF PROGRESON CIVILT.
NATIONALALRATE THE
WASHINGTON FOR JOBS AND FREEM VM
KING'S "I " SPEECH 3 MARCTODAY
BUT THLEBRAT
WEJONN CANIEWA FOR THE9
PROJECT.
IF IT'I LLNIKOLE, WH'S
TOHORRIBG
HA
A OF
TH60th OF THE
MARCH ON WASHINGTON FOR  AND
AWFUD FAO COMMONNDER THAT, SK T
MARK RACISM, RACIAJUSTIC
OURSELASG TH60 THAS S EVERY DAYD
ANNIVERSARY OF THE MARCHGTON AL
IN FACT,T WAS EVOKING
HISTORY  S THAT THE RU
R LI, E STRUGGLEO
END RACISMLE T
AND THIS IS JUST DEVASTATING
EXAMPLE OF>> OBVIOUSLYHINGS HAVE
IMPROVEDR CIVIL RIGH VOTING NDE
NGS ACT AMONTHEM.
THINK AOTRACISM
IS?
OR WE
HAVE COMD HOFA N AS  YES.
I IBS WOULEND THAT023  THEAME AN
BUT WHAT'S ALS
HAVES THEN WE
Y IND OF
AMERICANS IS TWICEHAT OF WHITE
THE RACIALEAS
ER. KING WSASSINATED.
CT THAT WE SEEIALIZE
VIOLARY SHOWS THAT WST
A AY G
THE SUPREME COUR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION THAT YING TOR
THE VOTIIGHARDER FORO OW THAN I
ASECOME OBSESSEDHE NOTION THAT .
S
AS WWHETHER WE'RE MOVING FORWARH
WE ARE AS A SO A TODAY DEERIZED
TI T O
JA>> BUTSED
DIFFERENTLY TODAY.
PROUEGN RSM LEST
GEORGIA BECOMING THE GOVEROFORL.
BUT LESTERULHE HE DIAY E  RIGHT?
WH ISSS TODAY
EX DISCRIMINATE AGAINST ACK AMNO
LEARNED OVER THE LAST 6S THAT
ONS PLATFORM AGAINST
WHATE  US WHO STUDY
HISTORY, WHO UNDERSTANTH
SOCIETIES WE LIVE INND
TH CODED AS LANGUAGE
AGAINST BLACAMERICANNG
MARGINALIZED GROUPS.
AFIN STATE. AD GELSA LANGGE
.
PRETTYE NATIONALIST .
WE SEEEOKE TUC
CARLSON WHO ARLO
ON TCHED N IN
D WHENLYLITSTHIS WA